[Music]
it is
no secret that the french boast their
fair share
of counter-strike legends for starters
there's the eternally worshiped kenny s
whose nutty ass no no-cap no-scopes
continue to make
op-wielding wannabes everywhere
weep and nico nearly dead eight oh
what is that from kenny s then you've
got
shaksi a ponderous pretty boy who looks
like he should be composing love poetry
instead of clapping fools with an ak
the only thing cleaner than this dude's
facial hair are his impossibly crispy
one taps
he almost took down two that is a
ridiculous shot though
sharks falling back into the bomb side
do they really want to chase him
he seems to be in a position he's taking
him down
and then of course there's zywo the
fragger about whom the prophecy foretold
born on the very day of counter-strike's
retail release
this beautiful baby-faced assassin is
so inhumanly talented that he's been
branded
the game's chosen one an electronic
looking for the cleanest finish she's
been
turned on daiwu no health really but
he's still hitting shots he's already
got three and four
and five and oh my god
suffice it to say when it comes to
clicking heads these baguette obsessed
bruisers
are as the kids say built different
but that don't mean they're built to
last whether it's because they
missed a crucial shot or just got kicked
for what feels like the zillionth time
the french are famous for letting their
emotions
get to them and sometimes floundering as
a result
this should tie things over 12 12. still
the advantage towards faze but
i'm going to be struggling it's another
partial by the lost weather starts to
rack up for them and still
quite dangerous will go down first shots
from easy
rain and kerrigan again they steal the
round very fast play toward
the lobby position matt he pointed out
that full echo they lost against the
five
sevens pincering them in from rampant
upper that was a defining moment
and it's in situations like that where
if you're looking to get across the
finish line
you don't want some agile yet unreliable
sports car
you want something tough something
robust because when the chips are down
you don't want a two-seater you want a
[ __ ] tank
but flamey is his kryptonite again
just do that are you kidding me for 15
for matt points daddy just puts his
hands together
making magic happen doesn't even smile
doesn't even cheer
enter cedric rpk gripri
the stoic stone-faced silver-haired 31
year old
who's been holding it down alongside
france's finest
for well over a decade
unlike many of his kinsmen rpk has long
been regarded as an altogether
unemotional assailant
a silent yet slippery sentinel who's
strong in any position
and able to stay calm and collected in
even the tensest
of circumstances a reputation that's led
him
to being dubbed the tank
world of tanks bro yeah
his most favorite still counter strike
let's see if he can clutch this
last player right above him both working
with minimal hp
and rp a was one better 13 frags
seven deaths eight health for the 1v3
clutch
le tank he does it zai will win rbk a
chance here to finish it all and take us
to inferno he's found boomage there's
two more where that came from
line flashed and punished one more and
one tap
the tank seals the deal gt moving as a
pack
oh dear jacks is going to dig down saiwu
apex and rpk left to hold on and now it
is just rpk the tank
and he's getting overwhelmed but tapping
them down tapping them out of the
round is rpk so how is it that rpk came
to embody this vehicular playstyle to
begin with
in what sense did his cs go career come
dangerously close to ending before it
even got started
and how is it that he's still able to
stonewall
zoomers despite being in his 30s
rpk tucked in on the elevator and called
sarah spots him out
this is the first and that's biggest
scalp done rpk's knocking off scalps and
handing out head shots
good grief i didn't expect that four
frags from the tank he's
just smashing through the competition
need to see that again
[Music]
now in spite of his age rpk didn't
actually get his start way back in 1.6
you see like a lot of these fragalicious
frenchies rpk
first began to make a name for himself
in scrubby old source
and unlike his contemporaries he wasn't
some up-and-comer
cutting his teeth in counter-strike's
notoriously sub-par
sequel no he was the finished article
and to this day is widely considered to
be source's
greatest ever player
rpk was aggressive absurdly consistent
and
able to hold down bomb sites like it was
nobody's business
and as a result he quickly earned
himself a second nickname
that emphasized just how large and in
charge he was
both in and out of the server the tank
wait how do they say in french
very games need to get that defuse if
they want to get themselves ahead again
rpk takes on shocks comes in smiz grabs
two of his own
molech rpk again and again he takes out
smiz rpk
and apex versus mullick can they do this
one versus two
molecules on apex can he clutch this for
uh dragons comes in rpk says no and he
ripped the set off
and somebody jumped over rpk uzi gets or
drops nbk
and yes rpa gets one gets the second one
on to uzi that's three so far
and it's all down to scream and heatran
the issue of course is that source never
really flourished as an esport
at least not in the way that 1.6 did so
by the time global offensive came around
rpk and his compatriots were eager to
prove themselves in what was heralded
as a unification of the franchise's two
previous titles
and he did at first
kind of you see rbk's cs go debut was
made on the then
world class very games roster a
veritable
super team made up of the greatest
sorcerers france had to offer
and from the get-go they were a force to
be reckoned with
toppling virtually every lineup that
ventured to get in their way
well everyone except for those [ __ ]
swedes thanks in large part to this
absolute e-gamer known as get right
ninjas and pajamas were the one side
that very games couldn't crack
and it heralded a brief yet unwitting
rivalry between the gods of source
and 1.6 as they vied for glory and go
i only have one basically memory of him
and we're sitting outside
and having a drink on one of the
evenings just sitting there before it's
getting
dark and there's like there's a nice bmw
just drives up
in front of the hotel and he just sits
there
just quiet and all the sudden he has
like mammals in french about like how
[ __ ] sexy the car
is and then they start laughing everyone
and then they explain it to me like that
barbie casey's
own world right now as always sees a car
and gets in love with it
but unfortunately for lutong get right
was just too
sneaky beaky to be bested and by the end
of 2012
rpk had lost his fourth consecutive
grand finals to those annoying ass 87
and owers
despite putting on the performance of a
lifetime back over here with rpk he's
down to a one versus three he's going to
enter up here with freiburg here in just
a moment you can see fryeburg
set up shop he will get taken out there
by rpk
as now that it looks like we've seen a
rotate happen here by get right but the
bomb carrier
actually is over inside of mid and rpk
goes down
and it was right then after playing go
professionally for three months
that rpk decided to call it quits
not because he couldn't beat nip mind
you but because despite being the second
best roster in the world he wasn't
making a lot of money
now remember this was in the very early
days of cs go
the french scene was in a state of flux
and given how god-awful of a place cs go
was in at launch
the game's future remained very
uncertain and being
23 rpk needed to get a real job
one that would pay the bills
[Music]
[Music]
successfully
so despite having been a competitive
source player for half a decade
rpk walked away from counter strike
completely
and turned his attention towards his
other lifelong passion
cars
automobiles
um
for two years rpk washed his hands of
counter strike he didn't even watch
events
since he thought it might tempt him to
make a return and right as it appeared
as if that
head head-clicking chapter of his life
was forever closed
the craziest thing happened weeks before
dreamhack winter 2014 was set to kick
off one of france's most promising
up-and-coming stars
cali got slapped with the most
scandalous vac man
in the history of professional cs go you
know that famous usp shot he hit on
pasha
the one that qualified them for the
major well uh
in retrospect this one's right on crisp
clean lock boys having been disqualified
from the major
cali's roster titan needed a replacement
whose
size and stature could save them from
the pr nightmare that they'd been
plunged into
so in a desperate bid to rehabilitate
their image
they sought out the tank just when i
thought i was out
echoed it pulled me back in needless to
say
cs go wasn't the same janky excuse for a
successor as when rpk had last laid eyes
on it
on top of that things had evolved from
the esports perspective
the crowds the stickers the player
counts
it was a whole new world of possibility
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
the question was whether he'd be able to
shake off the cobwebs
keep in mind this wasn't some six-month
astralis-esque vacation
this was two years which can feel like
an eternity in esports
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but the crazy thing is that in spite of
how substantially the game had changed
it didn't actually take that long for
the tank to start
rolling people again gonna meet guardian
here in a second but not before guardian
has taken down mania they've also lost
apex well look at rpk
you sneaky sneaky man behind three of
them he gets himself two oh no he needed
one more bullet
does in the end get three before the
plant happened crucially
before the plan when uh went down there
and he's even
trying to get it fourth now oh he's
excited maybe even get a fifth is zeus
coming around the side he will kill zeus
you've got to gift the man he's ace now
and the triangle's already set up here
for nip there's a man forest waiting in
the vents there's a man at the back
right they have no idea they just now
figure it out rpk hits one great
headshot a second one as well
and the ace this is it rpk the legend
from source he actually comes through in
the pistol round
unfortunately he struggled to find the
right roster
now it's no secret that french
counter-strike is
well a bit of a soap opera for years the
region stood in disarray thanks to a sea
of
kicks ousts mutinies and blood feuds
and since rpk was at his core an anchor
he wasn't always able to find the right
cast of superstars to support
despite being a genuinely adored player
he wasn't amassing the kinds of
accolades that his reputation seemed to
warrant
and at some point it started to look as
if he'd never achieved the kind of
success in go that his
legendary status in source had all but
assured
but fortunately for us the tank couldn't
be stopped
just as 2018 was coming to a close two
months after his 29th birthday
rpk signed on to become the rock of
vitality's brand
spanking new cs go squad there he joined
forces with a cast of tried and true
tusslers
to rear the greatest prodigy the game
had ever seen and they didn't just
perform
they took over the world you know this
is the kinds of games he was bred and
born in
being another newcomer but the pistol
round
starts to
step out headshot available nitro does
not want to repeat too soon
at the car good response from apex
another step further he might not have
had the angle rpk last alive but the low
end
it belongs to him and so does the round
for vitality
what kind of money can i pick oh that's
a beautiful shot wow
that's liaz hitting the dirt
oh another one the follow-up from rpk a
one versus two and he's got a real
chance
he's gonna drop down vents he might have
an opportunity to get the bomb planted
but gratisfaction has read it he's got a
little bit of a jump but he doesn't have
the hp to press the issue
at least a plant for rpk and a chance to
win a one versus four
that would be huge the monotone is going
to limit his space down here but now
he's out in the open
he just wants to continue on that one
shot head shot situation and
he actually falls back here they're
gonna line up for him he gets one oh my
god
the one versus four
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
by the end of 2020 rpk had helped
vitality secure themselves as a
contender for
the best counter-strike roster on the
planet
they're stepping towards rpk he's gonna
give chase there's three t's here
and of course he shuts down the front
runners
he has been a monster went 27 and seven
versus mousesports the other day
time ticking quick the op shot draws his
attention and zee woo takes the kill
vitality ladies and gentlemen are your
blast
fall finals champions at 31
the tank has not only climbed back atop
the game he loves
but is actively rewriting the book in
terms of what it means to be
too old to play competitive cs at a
truly high level i think rpk is the
epitome of
simple and efficient cs right he's not
gonna do fancy tricks with smokes and
whatnot he plays
simple counter strike holds down the
angle frags i also think he's one of the
best teammates you could ever hope to
have
never is he gonna complain about
position never he's gonna ask to have
more you just tell him what he's
supposed to do
and he's going to make the best out of
it
important
foreign
should he win a major tomorrow rpk would
be
the oldest victor in the history of
counter-strike
and while he isn't as spry as he was in
his source days
he's pioneered such a calculating
consistent
fundamentals heavy play style that
honestly
it doesn't really matter and while he
may not be the flashiest player in the
world
he sure as [ __ ] the most sustainable
after almost
15 years the tank is still out for blood
to this day he's rolling over scrubs
like it's his day job
because at 31 it still is
and he is showing no signs of slowing
down
rpk and apex both here again 20 seconds
left on the clock rpk
the tank kicked things off and he has to
do it all and he does as well
three kills for rpk i i think he might
still have it
i don't know if it works here but i
really want to do the [ __ ] you know
the french google translate meme you
type like darth vader
into like google translate and then you
you go into the french one
and you type in darth vader and it's
just like
and the meme is that you just do this
with anything
i saw one that was just literally i
think it was the original actually it
was just titties
it was just like titties and then just
it to these
just hard cuts to like boobs with like a
baghead and like